يشير القس إلى
مسرح الجريمة في لارجو أرجنتينا المزدحمة بروما،
ويشير إلى المكان الذي حدثت فيه جريمة القتل
خلال منتصف شهر مارس عام 44 قبل الميلاد،
وكان مجلس الشيوخ منعقدًا وهناك
اغتيل يوليوس قيصر على يد
المتآمرين وطعنه 23 مرة، كما يقول
جيوفاني، وهو مهندس معماري للإشراف  عملية
الترميم
جيدة، لذا فقد حدثت جريمة القتل منذ فترة،
ولكن الآن بعد أكثر من ألفي عام،
يمكن للزوار إلقاء نظرة فاحصة على المكان الذي
يعتقد المؤرخون أن أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الروماني
أرسلوا الدكتاتور المحتمل
لسنوات، وكانت القطط الضالة هي التي جاءت ورأت
أنها غزت هذه الساحة الآن  يتعين على
السلطات في روما إفساح المجال للسياح، حيث تتوق السلطات في روما
للاستفادة من انتعاش السياحة
بعد الإغلاق الوبائي، حيث
كشفت مؤخرًا عن مسرح خاص تم
بناؤه لإمبراطور مجنون تم تخليده في
ملحمة 1951 الرائجة،
وهنا عبقري التاريخ الشرير نيرو،
اكتشفنا من
لقد كان إلهي نيرو حالة كلاسيكية
مثل عالم الآثار المقيم في الغرفة داريوس آريا
لزعيم يعتقد أنه يعرف أفضل
ولكن في مرحلة معينة أدرك أنه مع
تقدمه في السن، انتظر لحظة،
أستطيع أن أفعل ما أريد هؤلاء الرجال الذين
ينصحونني بأنهم  "إنني منعني
من ذلك، يمكنني التخلص منهم، من يقول أنني لا أستطيع،
كان المسرح يرتدي نيرو، وهو
شاعر موسيقي ورياضي
شحذ الفأس للترفيه عن الجماهير، وكان يحب
الخبز والسيرك بشكل كبير، لقد
انتهى الخبز والسيرك الآن"
لا تزال هذه المدينة تجذب الجماهير إلى
روما